welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about how to make this
watch link designed into a ring
and a bracelet are you ready let's get
started
let's start with the ring first we're
gonna use the
circle and making the diameter for 16
millimeter and you do want it to work
on whatever ring size that you want to
start with
so for this one so i'm going to uh 3d
scale
it up for whatever thickness that you
want for your
ring bank and just a little bit over 1.5
and making a copy so we have something
like that i also wanted to
draw a straight line and i want to use
the polar array and see how many
sections that we'll need
for this one so let's give it a try we
want to use the
polar array the center is zero and let's
try
10 of them and see how big of the length
that is
so the 10 look good there and i think
this is a decent length so i'm going to
use that
so let me click that and i try to make
everything right in the center so i'm
going to rotate this one
for 18 degrees so then that will be in
the center
for the area that we're going to design
and i'm gonna using those two and trim
it off
this one so we don't have to deal with
the rest of the line so let me
go ahead and delete all of this
i'm going to use a rotate tool and
snapping into
this zero and make sure the copy equal
yes i'm just gonna move it out a little
bit like this
and then i'm going to mirror to the
other side
and something like this and the reason
is we are going to
use the curve in between here and i want
i do not want to over those two lines
that we
previously set it up so i'm going to use
those two curve
and trim off this area here and here
and try to use the blank command and we
want blend between here and here
and we actually want them to coming back
a little bit so we don't want to pass
that line over there
and let's click ok and again i'm going
to do on the other side
and bring it back to the line over here
all right and let's go ahead to join
everybody
now to make it into the solid we are
going to use
extruded planar curve straight and i'm
going to set it up
the extrusion for one millimeter on each
side so the thickness will be
two millimeter using the fillet edges
and set it up for point
two and let's fill the edge on one side
first and see how does that look
if that look okay to you we are going to
fill it on the other side
so this is the one of the element that
we are going to do the design
i'm going to set the stone here you can
watch the video for how to making a
diamond i'll put the link on the right
top
corner or you can download a stone for
this practice
and the link is in the description below
so i'm going to import a stone and i'm
going to bring stone
back about this size just a little bit
smaller
than our link and i'm going to
bring the stone up here you try to do
is having the girdle sitting on the
surface
something like this so coming in the
front view and i'm also
going to draw the cutter something like
this follow the stone shape
and going straight down like this and
using that line we
are going to use the command revolve
and snapping into the zero and do 360
degree and make sure you
cap on both sides so now we have this
one here
just making a copy by using the rotate
tool
and make sure that the copy is equal
yes and we want to moving the stone to
the side
over here and to be symmetrical i'm
going to use the mirror command
to mirror to the other side now we need
to have the bead right in the middle so
i'm going to draw the line
something in between like here and going
inside of the shape like this
and basically i'm just going to pipe in
this one
now i want to move the pipe going up
something like this
so that will be a b right in the middle
of my stone
and again i'm going to use the rotate
tool
and rotate one to the side for something
like this double check if it is the
right position
if it is it does let's go ahead to
mirror to the other side
and we want to select all four of them
and mirror to the other side as well
so then we will have the first link
there
i want to make a copy and hiding
and past and hiding one of them so we
can use that shape
later but in this one with the song
setting
i'm going to using the bowling
difference
and difference out this one this one and
this one
so that way i will have a stone sitting
in there
if everything looked to you and we can
choose boiling union
on this element okay so let's give it a
try
we want to go over here and let's do
the polar array snapping into the center
and we want 10 of them so they were
like almost touching each other over
there i also want to bring back
to the shape that we just hide it and
bring it
down somewhere about here you want them
to like slightly overlapping so you will
have a better casting and let's do polar
array on this one as well
we want a center to be zero the same
number for ten
so now with all of this one i'm actually
going to
rotate it for 18 degree so then they
will be
right in the middle for each of the
shape
and then i forgot to polarate the
stone so let's do the polar array again
so all of them will have storm
and if that look okay to you let's go
ahead to
mirror that to the other side
so then we will have this ring
perfectly for the size with all the link
there now this type of a ring
it's hard to size you almost need to
rebuild if it's the size is changing
for making the bracelet we're simply
going to pick up those
link
[Music]
and those three stone and i'm going to
copy them to the other layer
and let's turn this off and we are going
to look at the top view you can draw
whatever the length for your bracelet so
i simply going to draw a
minor a draw a curve going something
like this way and i'm going to move my
link to the beginning
if you look at the front view you notice
that there's a
angle there that we don't need it
because the
link is almost flat so i'm going to
rotate this guy
and bring it back something like this
we also need to have this having a
little bit more room because it's for
the bracelet if you don't have enough
room
it will break easy so before we are
doing anything else
i would like to using the cylinder and
to
making a pin over there radius
about 0.4 millimeter or 20 gauge
and i want to having a pin over there
and this pin can be coming out a little
bit
and then i want to make a copy to the
other side so i simply
wanted to mirror that pink
and snapping into this midpoint and
that's
moving into other side all right
so for those pin i'm going to making a
copy first
and hiding one of them and then we are
going to use a bowling difference
so this this this will be different
out from here here and here so now if
you're looking at the perspective
and then i have the pin over there then
what i like to do
is giving a fitted edges so you will
have
better rendering looking here so i'm
going to coming over here
and doing the fill edges here as well
and then we can bring the pin
back and for those pin over here
we actually want them to be a little bit
shorter for the rendering purpose
and again i do want to fill the edges as
well and let's try
something a little bit small so let's
try uh
0.1 millimeter and then we'll get
something here and here
and coming over here we're gonna do the
affiliate edges as well for 0.1
millimeter this is just look better for
the rendering as you can see if i do the
render view
you will feel like this is something
this is two different material over
there alright so once you set up
everything
make sure that it's in the right place
and we actually need another one i
forgot
over here so i'm going to
using that one and to be mirrored to the
other side
so all we need to do is boiling
different this one out of this one okay
so
now we have everything let's go ahead to
group them temporary
and i would like to make sure that it's
aligned with the curve that i'm going to
array so let's give it a try i'm going
to use the
transform that you have array along
curve
and i'm going to pick up the base i
don't know how many we need it
maybe 25 so let's give it a try and
apparently 25 is not long enough the
base
curve is here and 28 here
all right so it's pretty close now
notice that this is for the rendering
purpose
so let's go ahead to ungroup this one
and we need to delete the very last one
here
okay so now with this everything seems
all right let's take a look on the
perspective
all we need to do is the clasp
so i have a clasp class showing you
uh 11 different type of a clasp and how
to make it
and you can actually download a file and
it's a 3dm file you can use
on your design so all you need to do is
bring in the file
and you wanted to draw a straight line
right here somewhere inside of that
plate
and you wanted to trim the extra here
and extra here
and all you need to do also is to uh
using the cap command so then this will
be
solid on the other side again i'm going
to bring
this one download directly from the
program
from the course and you can bring it
here and all you need to do again
is draw a straight line coming over to
here
and we want to use this one to trim off
this and that if you're interested in
the clasp course
and i will have the description on the
right top corner
and we want to bring this back to
[Music]
the right place so let's take a look on
the render view
then you will have the classic is ready
to go
then you will have this ready for the
rendering
i hope you enjoyed the video please
leave the comment let me know how you
like the video
and share my video so i can reach more
people thank you for watching
and i'll see you next
[Music]
you